This is a spirometer.
It's a tool to measure your
lung capacity and function.
Medical tools like this one
are built with an adjustment.
And it adjusts for race,
or as they call it in this
particular setting, origin.
So, I'm gonna check
African-American
and then we'll try it again
and I'll change
my origin, in this case,
and we'll see what happens
when I blow into it.
Race adjustments,
or race norms, are used
all over medicine
from assessing
kidney function
to determining
breast cancer risk
and even diagnosing people
with dementia.
The purpose is to make
more accurate predictions
about people's health.
But a recent lawsuit
from retired NFL players
accusing the practice
of being discriminatory
has brought national
media attention
to the potential harms of using
race norming in medicine.
Man: The practice,
widely known as "race norming,"
makes it harder
for black players to qualify
for compensation.
It establishes
a lower cognitive baseline
for blacks than for whites.
Basically you were done
before you started playing.
Lee: I need to learn more
about why these adjustments
are being used.
Are there actual genetic
differences between races?
Where did the idea of race
even come from?
Let's see what it does.
( theme music playing )
So these are my results.
FEV stands for
forced expiratory volume.
It's the amount of breath
you can release in one second.
95%, FEV 3.6.
I'm a specimen
of athletic achievement.
So, compared to other black men
like me basically,
my lung functioning
rather is pretty healthy.
So we're gonna do it
one more time,
and this time we're gonna
change my origin to white.
So, um, I'm considered
mildly abnormal right now.
My numbers--
my FEV is 76 percentile.
If this was black,
it would have been
96 percentile.
I went from being very healthy
to lightly abnormal,
and I'm curious
of this dramatic adjustment
from white to black
could be the reason why
someone might be misdiagnosed
just because
of their skin color.
So you guys have heard
the saying that race
is a social construct,
and I feel like
for the most part
we all believe that.
But there's a 2018 survey
that said one in three Americans
actually believe there's
a biological difference
between the races,
and that's kind of what
I'm trying to investigate
right now.
So, I need you guys to do
one thing for me.
Stand in front of this projector
and I'm gonna try and capture
your silhouette.
Okay.
Lee: Strike a pose.
- Ooh.
- Amazing.
Lee:
So you guys are both humans.
Everyone has between 20
and 25,000 genes,
most of which, 99.9%,
are the same.
It's that 0.1% that makes us
all individual or unique.
That 0.1% represents mutations
to your genetic code,
which become genetic variants,
and those genetic variants
can be anything
from physical things
like skin color,
hair color, eye color.
But what I'm here to talk about
today is one very specific
genetic variant,
and that's skin color.
All right,
so there are a few gene variants
that are related to skin tone
and pigment, right?
They're actually
what determine melanin
production in the body,
and melanin is what
makes skin darker.
And we know that there's
a correlation between
exposure to the sun
and melanin.
So dark skin helps protect
against the harmful effects
of ultraviolet light,
and the closer folks
were to the equator,
their skin remained darker.
And as we started to kind of
spread out across the globe,
lighter skin evolved.
Light skin helps
with the production
of vitamin D in the body.
At that latitudes,
they're less worried
about getting too much sun
and more worried about--
- Getting enough, right.
- Yeah, when you mentioned
the survey of whether
people think
race is biological,
I think basically this is
what they're thinking about.
- Right.
- If they see people having
different skin colors,
some other different
features, and they're like,
"I can see a difference."
And as you can see,
Africa has tons of diversity
and skin color.
Yeah, so when people try to
define a race category,
clearly they can't
use skin color.
It's kind of laughable,
honestly.
So, like, I mean,
this map captures skin color,
but it does not account
for other physical mutations
that happened over time.
I think when you would
look at those as well,
you would find that
they don't map onto these
continents so clearly.
I think that if you try to find
physical characteristics
of the racial categories,
you're going to fail every time.
In the last 500 years,
there's been even more movement
of humans across the globe,
and a lot of that was due
to the forced migration--
the transatlantic slave trade.
And with this increased exposure
and mixture of skin colors,
inferences were starting
to be made
about what someone's
skin color meant about them.
The idea that there was
a difference between races
and skin tones,
people started to succumb to
some pretty wild conclusions.
I want to show you guys
what I mean when I say that.
So this is John Brown.
A man named Dr. Hamilton was
performing tests,
experiments on John's skin,
to prove that black people
had thicker skin
than white people.
Their skin was better able
to tolerate working
outside in the sun,
and he would do things
like expose John's skin
to extremely dangerous levels
of direct sunlight.
And he did this for years
to try and justify
the belief that blacks were
meant to be slaves biologically.
But this belief of
skin thickness, it lingered
through medicine to today,
and it's being taught to kids
in medical school right now.
So, I'm a second year
medical student right now.
My roommate reminded me
of a time
when he was
in a suture clinic
practicing his
suturing skills on a banana.
He asked the question of,
"How do you know what
needle size to use
and how do you know
what thread size to use?"
The physician said it correlates
with the thickness of the skin.
So for example, the skin
in your eyelid is much thinner
than the skin
in your lower back.
But then they said
that needle size can also
correlate with
a person's ethnicity,
implying that different
skin colors have different
thickness of skin,
which isn't true.
That's literally how racism
is perpetuated in
the field of medicine.
I would imagine
we see similar misconceptions
around pain tolerance,
too, right?
I feel like
that goes hand in hand
with skin thickness.
The belief that one skin color
or one person of one race
is superior to another,
that is racism.
But that's not really what
I'm trying to investigate.
What I'm trying to investigate
is what role race
plays in medicine.
It seems like
a really tough question
because you're
talking about going,
like, more than skin deep
in asking whether there
are biological differences
in the way
that our health develops
and the kind of conditions
that we might be at risk for.
I'm a carrier of
the sickle cell anemia trait.
- Oh, right.
- For years, we thought
that was
a black disease, right?
That's what people
think of it, yeah.
Because it's so prevalent
among this one kind
of group of the world
and less prevalent
everywhere else,
we label that with
a kind of racial category.
Yeah, this idea that there
are diseases, right,
or medical issues tied
to a specific race, it's wild.
When we go to the doctor
and we check a box for race,
what is that information
actually being used for?
You being compared
to an average distribution
of healthy individuals
of your sex, your age,
and your race.
- Why is it being utilized?
- We know that blood
characteristics
like your red blood cells,
your white blood cells,
differ by race.
And so when I'm telling you
your white blood cell count
is X number, 100,
what does that 100 mean?
It only means something
if you're being compared
to a population average.
So I had a patient,
a firefighter,
and when we were doing
the test on his lungs,
the technician
immediately compared him
to African-Americans.
But I asked him what he was
and he said, "I'm half."
And in his case,
it benefitted him
to be labeled white
so he qualified
for disability benefits.
How much do
social determinants
affect health outcomes?
Things like housing,
things like exposure
to air pollution,
socioeconomic status,
all those things.
I think your zip code
for non-biologic reasons
is a bigger predictor
of health
and health inequities
than anything.
Shouldn't those factors then
be included in conjunction
with things like race
and age and gender?
So that's what we call
an empiric question.
We don't know the answer yet.
Until we do the studies,
we can't definitively say
if X disease is due
to social environmental
factors or purely biology.
Do you think these-- that this
race stratification in medicine
could potentially overstate
how much of a biological
difference there is
between members
of different races?
We could be either
overestimating your disease
or underestimating
your disease,
and I can't give you
a blanket statement.
We need to do the work
to actually determine
what is the normal
population distribution
for different racial groups.
So it makes sense that
you would want to be compared
to a population
that's similar to you,
but should skin color
be a part of that?
I've been looking online
for studies or situations
where race norming
has caused harm,
but if you were misdiagnosed
because of this,
it would be hard to quantify,
mostly because patients
wouldn't be aware
that these adjustments
were being used.
It's more about
the potential harm
if doctors start to rely
on metrics that have
no biological basis,
and it seems like it's an area
that's only beginning
to be studied.
I have found one recent case
of the consequences
of race norming.
It actually concerns the NFL.
So the race adjustments were
used in the neurological
assessments
of these former NFL athletes.
I'm getting ready to meet
Kevin Henry.
He spent eight seasons playing
defensive end in the NFL,
and he took out a lawsuit
against the NFL
specifically because
of this race norming.
- See them divots in there?
- I see that. There's a lot
of scratches in it.
What does eight seasons
in the NFL do to someone
physically, mentally,
emotionally?
My eight year career
was full of injuries,
full of things I had
to fight through.
Both ankles,
one of them twice.
Both knees, both elbows,
both wrists.
All my fingers been broke
at least once.
Both shoulders.
I've had ten or more
concussions,
and those are just the ones
that are documented.
I've talked to a couple
of other guys who said
they would be kind of
in a fog normally.
Right, right.
It takes you just a little bit
longer to make decisions.
What was it like watching
Kevin go through this
for eight seasons?
It was horrible.
He sits there-- "This is
hurting, this is hurting.
My head is hurting."
Like, the memories--
I'm the person that has
to make sure, you know,
the doors are locked,
the oven's turned off.
I don't care how much
money you have,
what kind of shape you're in,
you can't do anything
without that brain, man.
Initially,
what was your diagnosis
and what did the NFL say?
They denied me altogether.
And then I kept going back,
you know, getting reevaluated.
His lawyer did the research
and he was like,
- something's not right.
- From what I read,
it seemed like they were saying
that you entered the league
at a lower level of
cognitive functioning
than your white counterparts.
Which meant
that you needed to show
even more severe
cognitive decline.
Basically, "You were dumb
before you started playing."
- Oh, my God.
- "So, if you're claiming
that you're impaired now--"
He was already impaired.
Lee: Kevin was recently
reevaluated and diagnosed
with mild impairment,
which can lead to some
treatment and monitoring,
but no money.
His lawyer claims
that without race norming,
his scores would have shown
more severe impairment
and could have qualified him
for a monetary reward.
What drove you to file
the lawsuit initially?
I wanted this whole
race norming thing eradicated.
It allows them to have
an escape hatch, to me,
for the payments.
What would that--
that compensation
mean to your life?
So I'm in a situation right now
where who's going to hire me?
I've been diagnosed
with dementia.
How can I find a job?
I still have a mortgage.
You know, I still got a family
to take care of, to support.
I don't like talking about--
I don't like talking
about suicide.
But everything
that I got going on, man,
I'm battling depression.
Like, I just see this man
deteriorating every single day,
and it just breaks my heart.
It extends beyond just,
"I need help to pay
my mortgage."
- You need help to manage
your life.
- Right.
At least give us
some tools to work with.
Lee: The judge dismissed
Kevin's lawsuit,
but ordered the NFL and
the original settlement lawyers
to address
the race norming issue.
An NFL spokesperson
told me,
"The availability
of demographic adjustments
was designed
to avoid the misdiagnosis
of healthy individuals
as cognitively impaired.
The NFL nevertheless
is committed to helping
find alternative
testing techniques
that will lead
to diagnostic accuracy
without employing
race-based norms."
The thing is,
the more I hear about this,
the more I feel like race
is not a reliable category
for measuring
health differences.
And I keep thinking about
something that Dr. Burchard
told me when we last spoke.
Burchard: Race and ethnicity
are social constructs.
They're artificial
social constructs,
and it's different than
genetic ancestry.
So genetic ancestry
matters more than race?
I'm gonna go learn
a bit more about mine.
We talked about how race
can be a pretty crude metric
for skin tone.
The thing is,
race does correlate with
certain genetic traits.
I carry the sickle cell
anemia trait.
It turns out the trait
is a mutation that evolved
in regions of the world
where malaria was a major
problem and cause of death.
People who carry
the sickle cell anemia trait,
you're actually
somewhat immunized
from the most debilitating
parts of malaria.
So this is what we call
a selective pressure.
And that means that
I have genetic ancestry
in sub-Saharan Africa,
where malaria is
just really prevalent.
We took some 23andMe tests,
so I am curious what
my results are gonna be.
- And you really don't know?
- What I'm assuming then is,
like, 80% African ancestry.
And when you look at,
you know, the possibility
of doing genetic testing,
it can't actually tell you
anything about exactly where
your family members are from.
It can just tell you
what pools of DNA
your DNA correlates with.
- You ready?
- Yeah.
What the ( bleep )?
This isn't mine.
This is Christophe's.
What? What?
I'm gonna call my mom.
( line ringing )
Mom:
Hello, my love.
Uh, I'm looking
at my 23andMe results.
Why am I half white?
I don't even know
who I am anymore.
40%? It only says
53% sub-Saharan African.
Do you know--
that's barely half.
Where did all this white
come from?
My mother.
And probably from Daddy, too.
Mom, the math's
not adding up.
All right, I love you.
I'll talk to you later.
I love you,
too, sweetie. Bye.
Okay, bye.
But, Lee, you just told us
that there's a difference
between race
and genetic ancestries.
- So you're not 40% white.
- White.
- You share 40% of your DNA
with people who are European.
- With white people.
But it gets to the point.
Just because your DNA shows
a bunch of European,
it doesn't change the way
that society is gonna treat you.
Views me. Right, exactly.
I don't even know if I--
Am I mixed-race?
Like, is that--
And if you are,
what proportion of
African-Americans are?
Are mixed-race?
Probably a good majority
of us, right?
Which kind of makes
race so comical.
Because obviously my genetic
and thus medical picture
should be way more nuanced than
a black reference population.
The ideal would be
for everyone to have some kind
of profile like this,
and then that is your
more accurate picture.
What you were just describing
is kind of the future
of medicine
that geneticists are
working toward right now.
I'm gonna go talk
to this geneticist
who works at Columbia.
He's writing a research program
called the All Of Us Program,
and they want to genetically
sequence a million people
from all over the United States
so that we can move closer
to precision medicine.
I know over the last decade
we've seen these, you know,
tremendous advancements
in the way we understand
genetic ancestry.
Is that more useful
to medical professionals
or to the field of medicine
than race?
When we're thinking about
genetics in the clinic,
we don't care
where they're from.
We care what's sitting in
and that individual's genome,
not where their ancestors
came from geographically.
I think the best way
to think of race in medicine
is as a proxy
for other things,
and a lousy proxy at that.
We came across this story about
hepatitis C and how, you know,
there were different outcomes
in white patients
versus black patients.
70 million people worldwide
are infected with hepatitis C,
a blood-borne virus
that causes liver infection.
Practitioners were seeing
that patients
of European ancestry
recovered more easily
from infection
than patients
of African ancestry.
However,
a study found that DNA,
not geographic ancestry,
better explained why.
One particular part
of the genome had
a dramatic impact
on who was cured
and who wasn't.
Some people have the good
response gene variant,
and some people have
the bad response gene variant.
Lee: It was thought that
black patients didn't respond
well to the treatment.
But upon further examination
of the genome,
it was discovered that
23% to 55% of black patients
did in fact carry
the good response
gene variants,
meaning they would
have responded well
to the treatment.
But because physicians were
making treatment decisions
based on correlations
with geographic ancestry
instead of looking
at each individual
patient's gene variants,
black patients were
missing out on treatment.
The reason why race
was a bad proxy was because
it's not impossible to have
the gene as a black person.
It's just less likely than,
you know, your white
or your Asian counterparts.
And so what it tells you
is that you want to
look at the individual.
I mean,
this explains how folks
could be misdiagnosed
or just miss out in this case
on treatment entirely
because we used race as a proxy,
and we just thought,
"Oh, no.
Black folks aren't responding
well to this treatment."
We don't want to be making
important treatment decisions
based on weak correlations
with geographic ancestry or race
when we can do way better.
There are not even
that many examples
in the first place
where geographic ancestry
really makes a difference.
And the reason is that
we're all darn near the same.
There's of course
a few little places in
the genome where we differ.
Sometimes the reasons
are because there have
been different patterns
of exposure to
infectious diseases
in different parts
of the world.
Both:
Like sickle cell and malaria.
Can we get rid
of race in medicine?
I do have sympathy
for the perspective that
we should consider that.
I don't think that it
would be the best way to
practice medicine right now.
The best way
to practice medicine
is to not consider it
unless you need to.
- And I will keep going back
to the hepatitis C example.
- Love that example.
Let's say that we weren't
permitted to consider race.
The observation then
would not have been made
that individuals
of different
geographic ancestries
respond differently.
Race may have come from
thinking about skin color,
but the implications mean
so much more than that.
My skin color determines
how I'm perceived,
and that in turn
affects my health.
So from day one, it's been
really difficult for me
to wrap my head around
this question
because it seems like using
a metric as vague as race
can carry with it a lot
of incorrect assumptions.
However, there
are some correlations
with genetic ancestry
that seem to be helpful.
So, I've realized that
we need to support efforts
that will allow us
to remove the use of race
as a proxy for how we
administer treatment to folks
or how we determine
if someone's healthy.
In response
to a movement largely led
by medical students,
some hospitals
and universities
are removing certain
race adjustments.
We need to find solutions
that fix inequities
and not use race
as a best guess.
A few weeks after
we wrapped this episode,
the NFL pledged to stop
using race norming
as a part of how they were
evaluating brain injury claims,
meaning that players
like Kevin Henry
will likely be reevaluated
under a new testing protocol
that won't involve race.
It's still unclear
what that method will be
and what effect it will have
on future brain injury claims.
Uh, this is Best Episode,
act one, take one.
- Take two, marker.
- Did you say--
- Best episode?
- Damn.
Man: Careful.
This is mildly abnormal.
I need to call a doctor.